well look what we've seen is
unprecedented this is a crisis that was
made in number 10 we've had a run on our
currency
um yields up as a consequence and
people's borrowing their mortgages up
because of this government and then as
you listen to Jeremy Hunt what you hear
is despite long cues in the NHS it's now
set to get worse because it's expecting
that department to find further
efficiencies despite Rising class sizes
in Britain we can expect our education
to get worse and with crime soaring
across many communities in the country
we need police officers are they now
going to backpedal on those undertakings
that they previously made this is a
disaster and the only way to deal with a
disaster in our democracy is to have a
general election and to set our country
on a certain path for the next five
years we cannot live in an oligarchy
effectively where the conservatives
choose who leads them and as a
consequence gives us a prime minister
with no mandate no mandate at all to
make Now The Swinging cuts that we're
about to see well yes and he wasn't
specific about what kind of cuts in
which departments was he he said he
would be laying that out but he said it
was important to be honest with people
and say that there were going to have to
be some issues over spending and tax in
order to reassure the markets that the
sums add up isn't that the approach that
you need he said he wanted to be honest
look the truth is that there are still a
dividends cut proposed there's still a
cut to tourists buying luxury goods uh
there's still the stamp Duty Cuts we
haven't seen the obr forecast but we
know that the ifs says that there's a 62
billion pound hole and the corporation
tax reversal only deals with about a
third of that so there is a significant
problem still it's why after Liz truss
finished speaking yesterday the pound
continued to fall and interest rates and
borrowing Rose this problem was made in
number 10. this problem was made by Liz
trust she was warned during that
leadership campaign not to take this
course our borrowing is up and now we're
suffering Cuts because of this
government and we need to take that to
the British people and see if in a
general election this is the direction
that they want to continue to go going
well you say there's still a significant
funding Gap that's exactly what he's
saying that he's seeking to address
[Music]
French we were already facing a cost of
living crisis we were already facing
Rising Energy bill we now have a
mortgage crisis a pensions crisis
because of this government and we've
heard this morning we're now going to
get swinging Cuts this is in a G7 Nation
it's unprecedented what this government
has caused us
so you say that you want a general
election how will you try to make that
happen
well The Honorable thing when you're
facing a situation where we may get
another prime minister chosen solely by
conservative MPS is for the government
to say that actually we now need a
general election because of course any
government needs a mandate now we're
facing the mess that we are facing uh uh
it would be wonderful if conservative
MPS joined us and brought that about but
frankly The Honorable thing now is to
give certainty to our economy in the
global community and the only way you
can do that with a general election the
government could call a general election
today it's up to them
it's it's not likely to happen though is
it
well I'm afraid I think the idea
that our great country can stumble on
for another two years of this with no
political mandate uh with further Cuts
in our economy with inflation now going
up as a consequence of decisions that
they made even further people are
suggesting 14
our country doing really badly in the
G20 I think only Russia's economy is set
to be worse than ours this is
unprecedented and it's why in all
seriousness the only way we can bring an
end to this is with the general election
and the government should call one put
this to the British people and see if
this is really what the British people
want